I understood that you waited tables here
in Chicago but you started waiting
tables back in Georgia
oh yes that's old hat for me really are
you good at waiting - what kind of
restaurant did you work it well I was a
real good waiter but working at a
restaurant called po folks when you
didn't it was called po pho yep Pio
' folks which is a cute cute way of
saying poor people yeah and this is the
restaurant where you were restaurant it
was all fried food it was you know
homestyle cooking but you know like
they'd have blast strips hanging from
the ceiling you should go there y'all
and was it a pleasant experience did you
find like the clientele were nice to you
well cuz you seem like someone who would
never lose their temper that is what I'd
like to maintain but sometimes your
buttons get pushed and one time I was
waiting tables at po folks and this
family of four this ragtag little
hillbilly family was sitting there with
all due respect to Georgia but they were
running me ragged and you know they were
stealing all the little grape jellies
and all the butters and stuff and I was
like going grocery shopping at pocos so
they're running me ragged and then as
they left they didn't leave me a tip and
I'm like well that is the last straw so
you got mad I followed them into the
parking lot and I was like excuse me is
there a reason why you did not leave me
a tip because I felt I gave you great
service this little eight-year-old girl
goes uh mama should I I yeah yes
lady do that this eight-year-old child
opened up her Hello Kitty pocketbook
took out a $1 bill and I snatched it
[Applause]